hey everybody welcome back to elemental
garden today I'll be working on the
entrance building and the main streets
of the park or at least part of it and
it'll all be pretty much in a very
similar modern style to wanna make the
observation towering so let's get
started and actually build the street
itself I wanted to make sure that I had
the the general look of the street
before I went into the buildings that
I'm going to place around it's actually
make the Main Street and I think it I
can actually make my own lamppost over
here because looks a bit more
interesting I guess then the in-game
lamppost which are going to get boring
after a while and it's pretty easy to
just build one of these and then just
copy it around around the park so I went
ahead and just made a very simple modern
lamppost I have to say the entire Main
Street is going to have a very modern
kind of style to it more about that
later because it's not necessarily
modern but um yeah more about that later
anyway it's very contemporary not
exactly futuristic but just very recent
style to the entire Main Street which is
kind of weird for an amusement park
but then again that's also kind of why I
wanted to try it so I've got the lamps
in there and which are all looking very
modern and sleek and I figured one way
that I could solve the problem of these
lamps not actually being functional like
the in-game lights are was to put a area
light under the ground underneath these
lights to kind of make them still
function as actual lamp posts and that
is actually something that works quite
well so you can very easily just make
your own lamppost and make sure that
they're actually lighting up the area
underneath and around them by placing
the area lights wherever you need to so
that was something I did and afterwards
I figured I would quickly get into some
planters for the side of the sidewalks
here because otherwise the entire Main
Street which is turned into a sort of
barren desolate lightless Street and
that with something then I definitely
wanted to avoid so these planters along
with the 3s that are going to sit inside
them should hopefully add some
much-needed greenery to the Main Street
and make it all a little bit cold
because even though I am obviously going
with a very modern sort of architecture
style I didn't want everything to become
white and sleek and clean and lifeless
but I wanted to still make it somewhat
charming to at least still make it the
street worthy of a theme park
anyway after doing that I figured it was
right about time to actually get into
the entrance building itself and now
this is quite interesting is it's a bit
of a contemporary classical building in
a sense then I am really just drawing
from classical temples and arches and
such but doing it in a very simple
geometric sense so I'm using a lot of
the odd primitive pieces actually and a
lot of the simple roof colors and
anything that has a very flat texture
and shape to it to make this building
here so while it still follows pretty
much the conventions of any classical
building with having the pillars some
arches in the middle actually make it
still a little bit more fancy and add
some detailing to it and on top of that
having the architrave and fries it's all
very simple
so it's reflecting the general look of a
classical sort of gate like this but in
a very modern simple way and I figured
this was a good way to get along with
the look of the tower because especially
around the base of the tower I had those
sort of pillars going round which very
much reminded me of round Roman temples
and yeah that's why I figured having an
entrance like this and very much similar
colors and a generally similar style
through the tower in the middle of the
park would make sure that these two
structures are kind of working and
hand-in-hand as you're approaching the
park
and the detail which at this point in
this episode is not going to happen yet
but it's also one interesting to mention
is that I'm not going to leave the top
of the building like this at the moment
it is just flat but in some future
episodes I'll be putting the pax logo on
top of that because one of the one of
those sort of things that we had to do
in order to submit our park and actually
make it work for Tex East was to
incorporate the tanks logo in some way
either in the entrance building or in
some kind of centerpiece for the park
and I my sort of mind which was winging
this entire episode just figured that
putting the pax logo on the entrance
would probably work best because you
have these two similar structures and
I'm working together with the entrance
building and the observation tower and
then sort of in the middle of that and
very much being a very bright red logo
that immediately gets your attention
there is the big banks logo on top of
the entrance building and that should
hopefully make very clear what this park
is and what it's all about to any guests
in-game I guess walking into the park
but also anybody looking at the park and
stunning at the entrance and I'm just
finishing the wings of the station here
for a couple of reasons
partly just to you know have a head
space where you can actually have the
ticket booths where you can buy your
ticket realistically obviously that's
not something I have to keep in mind for
planet coaster but it's just a small
detail that I at least wanted to keep in
mind to keep some sort of belief that
this could be a real theme park and also
to kind of cover up what is going to be
behind this because right behind this
I'll have the Main Street and instead of
having the ugly size of buildings I just
wanted to make sure that I had one wide
coherent entrance building so I'm trying
to cover up what is going to be behind
these areas in the Main Street by making
the entrance building a bit wider on the
side here and again this was a pretty
good time to make use of the
coppy tools in planet coaster and just
grab that entire point copy that around
to the other side and that is basically
it for the entrance building it's quite
simple but so is the rest of the park
pretty much and in the end I'm quite
happy with it even though it's very
simple and quick sort of way to get to
where I wanted to I think it still kind
of works it's an entrance that gets your
attention but not too much still draws
you into the park but you can already
kind of see the glimpse of the
observation tower in the distance much
like you can see the claims of that this
is the Cinderella's castle or whatever
castle in one of the Disney parks at the
beginning of the main street so just to
address everything up a little bit more
and add some more detail to it I figured
I would play some of these plungers on
the side I will definitely work a bit
more on this Plaza in the future and add
some extra trees and foliage to it at
some points but at this point I was
really only concerned with finishing it
to the point okay everything that were
too much in my lost temperatures but I
was really just concerned with making
sure that I had enough of the first
plaza to kind of get an idea of what
that was going to look like so that I
could finally move into the main street
and actually experiment a bit more with
that and before I did that I wanted to
quickly make some fancy puffs over here
at this point I was still being very
naive and thinking that I could actually
make part works like this in the rest of
the park there's no way I could just
takes way too much time and it's also
not the best thing for your computer but
anyway at this point it is about time
that we get into the Maestri I just
realized at that point again but yeah
we're getting into the Main Street and
this is quite interesting and quite
weird and also most likely going to be
quite polarizing since it's a weirdly
contemporary Main Street I'm not going
with any traditional styles or anything
since that would very much just clash
with the look of the observation tower
but I'm also not going with the sort of
past
future vision of sci-fi architecture or
anything that is that is very
fantastical or from any kind of modern
fantasy religious going with some kind
of building style that could almost fit
in a new urbanist part of a city and is
really almost more like an actual city
street than a Main Street and one of the
first buildings that I wanted to try
here is just a simple building with two
parts actually many of these buildings
are going to be built up of two parts
and I'm not sure why but the building
just keeps reminding me of a bit of a
Japanese style to it still not exactly
sure wise but it's a modern building
with some stone detailing and I would
say for especially buildings like these
which are very simple and I'm really
just keeping it to clean lines and
geometric shapes in these buildings for
these kinds of buildings the texturing
for me was the most important thing and
much of this Main Street was also just
an experiment with different styles I
don't think all of these buildings
really succeeded on an equal level and
some of them definitely don't even fit
that well into a theme park but I think
they've all been pretty good
experimentations
and like short little mess about with
the pieces in planet coaster especially
when it comes to textures because when
you're building like this the texture
and the way that the material looks is
just so important in the way that a
building in the end looks so I was
really happy to see how the colors of
the stone work together to sort of give
you this very muted natural stone look
also the way that the stone pillar
pieces together can give you these very
thick stone walls that you can surround
a building with is something that I
really liked about this building and I
just figured it would be much more
interesting than just a simple box out
of simple shapes because that was
something I wanted to avoid and this
sort of brings me to
topic that I wanted to discuss about
architecture even though I am not very
knowledgeable about modern architecture
at all I've never followed anything in
that field and it's just a bit of an I
guess an interest but something that I
thought was very interesting when I look
this up for the park to actually talk
about this is that there's actually a
very clear difference between
contemporary architecture and modern
architecture and they're very often just
lumped together as the same kind of
thing which nobody knows exactly what it
is but everybody knows when they see it
but they're actually very different
things and modern architecture is
essentially not that modern in a sense
than it mostly refers to a style of
architecture which was very popular in
the early twentieth century also the
sort of mid 20th century and
contemporary architecture is not a
specific style of architecture but
anything that's being built right now
but as I understand it it's also mostly
used to not refer to anything that's
built right now that is for instance
still looking like very old architecture
like classical it's also not referring
to anything being built right now that's
very futuristic it's anything that's
built right now that doesn't really fit
in those exact categories that it isn't
is basically contemporary architecture
so contemporary it's really the style of
the current year in a sense and modern
is a bit of an old style from a few well
quite a few years ago actually and as
far as I understand most of these
buildings are much more contemporary
than they're actually modern even though
most people actually call these
buildings modern because that that's
kind of how you feel about it at least
that's what I would have caught them not
so long ago but for instance is some
things which make these buildings a bit
more interesting and would probably make
them more modern than or really more to
make them more contemporary than modern
is for instance this little cantilever
on the building which
right now which is the wooden parts that
sticks out like this and it kind of
breaks up from the rest of the building
if it were a modern building it would
probably still have the same height as
the rest of the building the entire
building would have probably been the
white plaster and everything would have
fit together in a very simple very
simple elegant way but instead I sort of
chose to lift this part that sticks out
up from the rest of the building gives
it a different texture arrange it
differently
so that it really sticks out from the
rest of the building and that's more of
a thing that contemporary buildings do
it's also something that is very much
like all of the modern houses that
people build in Minecraft which I never
quite found an exact style for but it's
that kind of style which I guess you
could very much compare through what I'm
doing here but mostly I was just having
fun
just messing about with the textures in
the game and one of the things that I
really wanted to try was to kind of
create my own gloss if not entirely but
I wanted to have some gloss ish texture
that would at least have a color that
could potentially look like some gloss
even though looking at it I'm not too
sure about it um but the reason I wanted
to try that was because the in-game
windows just don't really work for this
kind of architecture and I also wanted
to avoid the in-game modern windows
since they have a very strict framing to
them that I didn't want to use for these
windows so instead I took up the 3d what
are they calling in the art primitive
shape and make them out of that which I
guess is alright we can definitely tell
that it's not actually glass and I could
have still messed with that a little bit
hopefully but in the context and having
some foliage around it and having the
people run it as well as some more
detailing I think it works well enough
and it definitely gets the idea of the
building across
so moving on to what is going to be the
last building of the main street for now
I wanted to finally build a bit of a
simple new urbanist ish row house out of
bricks and again my my main thing that I
kind of wanted to try here was to
combine different sort of washed out
colors to make the bricks look as nice
as I could and not make them too
cartoony like bricks often turn out
implanted coaster but also not make them
to medieval or rustic but hopefully get
the texture just right for that sort of
yeah that muted very contemporary look I
guess and awesome that's something that
I was flying out here and again I'm
trying to make my own window since the
ingame windows didn't have the exact
spacing that I was looking for and that
is basically going to be the entire
building it's very simple and it's very
straight to the point I did want to make
it as clean as I could which is why I
ended up using these stucco pillars
instead of using any wall arches or
anything like that because I want is it
I wanted the entrance be perfectly
square and perfectly seamless with the
toilet but I decide it's just a very
simple building but I think it goes well
for this building goes what for many of
the other buildings go as well is that
they're very simple in terms of looks
but still some of the objects the kind
of hero objects actually make them
happen and they definitely go against
what you're supposed to do with these
kinds of objects in planet coaster I
haven't said it yet so that I would
really love to get into some more like
modern architecture and flowers coast at
some point in the future if maybe at
some point we possibly have some glass
pieces like making skyscrapers and stuff
like that is something that I would love
to try and always like to mess around
with a little bit in rollercoaster 3 and
I haven't really had the opportunity to
do so in planners coaster so far but
it's definitely something that I I might
try at some point in the future anyway
we now have toilets in the park and it's
the only pointed entrance
or only point of interest Jesus what
happened to my English but it's the only
thing that people can really go to the
parks and everybody is going to the
toilet and leaving the pike again so
that's pretty 12 and I think that's also
all for the the Main Street attractions
that people can actually go to literally
people are just able to go to the toilet
for this section of the Main Street I
didn't want to break up the other
buildings by placing any facilities in
it because that would sort of break the
perfect sort of clean look that the
building's had so far but I will
definitely feature some more modern or
some more actual facilities in the Main
Street so there will actually be some
info places and some food and drink
stuff but for now the toilet is where
we're standing and that's all I have for
now
funnily enough this will actually be the
only toilet in the park which I was not
so sure about when I finished the park
whether I should really keep it that way
but I checked the guests and nobody was
complaining about the lack of toilets
there were some thirsty people and some
hungry people but apparently the people
are fine with having one set of toilets
at the entrance of the park so I mean I
guess I'll take that I have no idea why
that's even the case but honestly if
they're all served by these toilets and
they're okay with walking to the other
side of the park I'll take it
it's not something I'm going to complain
because it's more or less the opposite
of a problem for my case here so yeah
that's there's going to be the toilets
everybody's going to have to deal with
for the rest of their stay in the park
they're going to probably end up being
the worst and the most smelly toilets
ever
but then again toilets in the theme park
or well actually no they're not that bad
what am i what am i complaining about
the toilets in might with the employer
coverage is bad but placing the trees in
the main street just made me realize how
much trees just make everything look
better and I wish that could be straight
like everywhere weather which streets
around both the sides
certainly there are way too many streets
in this world without trees and that is
a very sad thing indeed because trees
are awesome
what's also awesome is some
around the edges of the building kind of
reflecting the lights that I had around
the observation tower it's literally
just that same kind of theme and
especially if you would be looking at
the entrance at night and seeing the
entrance with the observation tower in
the distance the idea is that they'll
have this sort of matching style in
terms of the lights there we go that
should give you a pretty good idea of
how it's going to look eventually and we
have that interesting sort of neon
outline to both of the buildings which
should hopefully make them fit in quite
well together now as a general lighting
tip and I use this plenty of times
before but I haven't really explicitly
given a shout out before as a little
lighting tip which I got from night II a
very long time ago so if you're watching
this thanks man a very quick lighting
table is that I usually do use the area
lights to light up all of my areas
because they have a light source that
actually extends out of the light itself
so you can use it the very sneakily line
up buildings without actually making
visible light that's something I wanted
to quickly end this video with because
I'm out of the time lapse so thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
guys in the next video
[Music]
you
[Music]